what's up guys Zachy here with GE
culture and today we will be exploring
the world of Evangelion with Rog yes Rog
and Studio Cara has teamed up to bring
Gamers and evangelon fans with their
latest and greatest Tech all right first
of all let's talk about the enormous
gaming chassis the help of my friends
here we have the Rog Hyperion Eva O2
Edition am I still in frame on the M uh
yes so this is the Rog Hyperion Eva O2
Edition gaming case as you can tell this
is huge all right just like the what do
you call a Mach just as big as the Evas
themselves I think we just got to open
it up man you also can see and I hope
the camera can get that we have
the Eva right here
too so just
carefully brother in my kitchen I also
not shop what's going on man by the way
this is d as well say hello D hi the
accessory box for the chess all right 3
two 1 all right
let's unveil this
man
yo
okay where do I even begin all right
folks now that we got this on the table
despite it being a little bit heavy all
all right let's take a tour of the r
Hyperion evo2 Edition now as you can see
we got two side panels we're going to
focus on this end first which has very
interesting design I I feel so
convenient my God we can open it up and
just swings like that it's kind of like
a magnetic clasp if you will all right
so it's very easy to pull out on top of
that you can actually lift up the hinge
and don't forget this is stepper glass
so just be very careful with it okay now
coming back to this this piece C
supports 420 mm dual radiators on top of
that you can see that we have four 120
mm fence in built we also have a metal
GPU holder and at the back we have an
argb Fan Hub now just looking at the
whole design and aesthetic of this
Chessie I mean this is all in Evangelion
fashion we got the Eva over here we got
a few motifs here as well and then we
got this nice design Motif over here and
you're probably asking yourself what is
going on over here you can actually
slide it to reveal something to hold and
what you can put in there is your
own uh R screwdriver that they provided
along with your additional accessories
like your screws and zip ties this all
comes with the case so if you ever
wanted to know how this screwdriver
looks like is just there we go just look
at the accents over here the design of
it is just amazing so when you do
eventually open open it up you know it's
like so with this whole front panel you
guys going to have a lot of cooling you
got ventilated designs all over the
chassis now looking at the io Parts over
here we have four USB 3.0 we got a 3.5
mm headphone jack two USB type- C's of
course you know your off and power
button now because you know we all love
our RGB you guys will also have a LED
function which you can so you can switch
around the lighting as and when you like
so with talked about ventilation and one
important aspect would be cleaning out
your mesh it's just as simple as that
just pull it out and when clean it clean
it and just slide it back as so let's
move on to the other side all right
folks so moving to the back of the
chassis you guys can see that there's
this red acrylic panel it's very easy to
unscrew it and take it out now we can
also see that there's this argb Hub
which controls pretty much the lighting
of the chassis and you can also slau in
the fans as well cool coordinates that
will probably lead us to somewhere and
if anybody can figure that out let us
know down in the comments below now just
above the argb Hub we can see that you
have two slots to fit in 2.5 in ssds or
hard drives and now moving to the rear
kind of nine PCI is not SP it's also
determined on your motherboard and
placement the slot for your PSU and your
IO parts for your motherboard now the
cool part is the top of the chassis not
only do you have rails to carry it up up
but the exhaust on the top here kind of
slides out and this is where you can
place your uh dual radiator fence so
with the chess out the way let's talk
about very special and very expensive
Hardway all right folks let's talk about
the motherboard what we have here is the
RG Maximus
z790 hero Eva O2 Edition it supports
ddr5 Ram 5times m.2 SSD slots and a PCI
Gen 5 support bought for our RX 490 and
our seate fauda 540 SSD of course it has
all the belts and whistles like Wi-Fi 6E
and two Thunderbolt four ports among
other things now for CPU we are going
with the Intel i
93900 k fully unlocked for all your
overclocking needs now in order to get
all of these running at optimal speeds
without throttling we'll be using the R
reuen 3 360 argb Eva O2 Edition and for
memory we will be using 32 GB of
Kingston Fury
ddr5 Ram running at a whopping 7,200
megat transfers per second and for
storage we'll be using the 2 TB Seagate
fire Cuda 540 SSD really fast read and
WR speeds offering up to 10,000
megabytes per second onto the fun stuff
what we have here is the RG STX RX 490
OC Eva O2 Edition pretty much says it
all 24 GB of gddr 6X vram lots of power
but also lots of cooling with the new
patented Vapor chamber with mil heat
spreader for lower GPU temps so
accompanying the GPU will be the r
Hercule X this is a GPU holder with some
argp as well we're going to swap that
out with the inbuilt GPU holder just to
give it more possessed bit more
lightning you know little more and as
the same those with great power comes
great responsibility and what we have
here is the RG Thor 2 Platinum Eva
Edition providing up to 1,000 wats of
power it also has the Eva inspired skin
here as well so all in all uh we're
going to be all in all I'm pretty
excited to get this up and running and
can already tell how awesome it's going
to look with all this themed components
that being said I would definitely need
some help so I'm going to rope in my
good friend Zeno
and of course our good friend over R
hello yes so Zen yeah put the PC before
right video right now bro how okay it
looks like we got to speedrun this all
right 3 2 1
[Music]
go
oh I'm ready
[Music]
[Applause]
now
[Music]
[Applause]
they almost there can't wait to check it
out are we going to do any overclocking
on this or pretty much it will take care
of itself so we actually do have uh AI
overclock so you just need to let it run
then you automatically tun to high spot
and while maintaining the lowest
temperature sounds good man let me talk
about the peripherals that we're using
right now what we have here is the r
strect scope
RX uh and the mouse we're using is the
Rog Gladius 3 wireless AO both in Eva O2
editions now for those of you who do
have an existing R RX switch keyboard R
also has these evangelon custom key cap
sets for them and this Eva O2 grip tape
skin for your R hop a mouse we've done
our bit you do the gaming portion and
the overall whatever okay yeah fine
let's go grab a beard here at GE culture
we tested plenty of chairs but Secret
Life gaming chairs remain one of our
favorites whether it's for work or play
they feel great to lean back against
with the ergonomic features offering
support for the whole body from the head
and back to the arms and even something
for your butt this mix of fourman
function helps the Titan Evo 2022
deliver the best seating experience like
no other for more information check out
secretlab.co all right so welcome to day
two of the build or rather already has
been built thanks to zi T and myself so
I'll be testing performance on this
thing with three games armor core six
Starfield and returnal and I'm expecting
really good things I mean if you're
going to spend this much cash on this
beautiful PC you you're going to need
great results right so with that let's
just get into the games all right so uh
post videos in here and I realized that
my initial recording of armor core was
not the best quality so I'll be
reshooting it again that's why I'm in a
different hoodie and everything cuz you
know we want to get it right here we do
things right here all right so with that
let's just keep going and let's get into
our settings real quick for graphics
we're in full screen 120
FPS V's on HDR is on don't need that
let's go to edit everything is on
maximum yes we on the highest set
think's possible for this game so with
that let's just get into the mission
bricks are off I sent you the mar
data let's head toward the elevator
going to the upper
level very nice all things going on but
honestly this game is cleaning out very
smooth like the other two games and kind
of complain honestly
bam you thinking he just walk straight
in
here hope you're watching
Boss leave it to Invincible rubby to
show our guest a good
sign Arena registration plan
I'll be skipping all the secret bits in
the inch of time but with that let's
just keep going and start killing
everything around us everything they
breathes oh noticed the fireworks I left
for you okay so we got those fall
down
left shoulder ammunition at
30% very nice and that should be it
great okay boss
time all right
so not exctly use to flying with this
kind of AC honestly I very much more of
like a lightweight out buil but I know
for this one it's a lot easier if I do
this way
easier
okay oh performance we doing very good
we're doing very we're doing amazing
they're doing an amazing job with
performance and just trying my best not
to get hit or
die all right we have him down
again I need to stay clear of those
things okay I just need to get down get
down here stop puming
him come on come on we're so close we're
so close we're so astronomically
close
ammun
okay oh that hurt that really
hurt
okay we done oh Lord okay so that
concludes the armor call and not one of
my best games I have to say but um
average FPS we are at 119 and for Max
FPS we are
229 so let's move on to the next game
all right let's check out settings real
quick and display everything this on
very high exit Ultra so I think we're
good oh
okay cont I have
changed why did you change me
assumption and range by the appropriate
human
responses there we
go was destroyed I mean like the first
SWAT five minutes is of the game really
like 132 FPS currently okay me it's
fluctuating of course with 147 average
and 234 for Max so I think we're doing
pretty damn good never
mind one down
oh no many rounds but you're going to
make
do okay we got a bearwolf and I got my
drum beat here nothing too crazy
very nice building real
quick suck the aocks and we're
in Easy
pickings
all
right just got one guy on this side we
take him
out oh yes I need
that
okay okay so there's bound to be a lot
of enemies down here so we're just going
to be taking everything
out opening shot one
off even when I
compensate there we go all right let's
leave this
[Applause]
place okay can I can I fast travel
now
please okay I can
nice
colonist thank you for responding we had
someone jump in and leave without even
we're with uh list but our grab Drive is
old let's see do listen we have kids
listening so we have a workbench here
but we need then we should be able to
jury rig Sumer we'll pay loads
more if you can find thank you okay
the average FPS of Starfield with this
RI it's 135 FPS and the maximum is 234
FPS so you know what like it's running
damn smooth I mean like temperatures
wise I mean we're around like 66 we
haven't even hit like 70 at any point of
time so we're doing pretty good all
right so uh next game uh let's check
settings can't play Graphics Graphics
epic everything's an epic 240 frames per
second
uh everything's an
ultra Fram reflex gam PS shed no I don't
need that like everything's on high race
Trace epic as well epic epic epic epic
everything is on Epic okay
z Oh 69 yep
69 okay and we ready to
go oh never mind let's keep
going o this is beautiful this place is
super smooth oh oh
oh very nice all the particle effects
anything going
on PC is not breaking a sweat of
course
here
girl okay that's once the SE Scot
Avenged and yes let's get
that don't need that okay we're doing
fine so far
though oh boy oh oh ohy oh boy oh
boy one by one take them out
methodically okay uh FPS spe is still
about
1,450
somehow get this one down keep
going Ries come on come on come
on
oh we can eventually Scout here oh okay
did not see that
okay something has infected one of my
Scout
corpses
okay that's not
good that's not good that's not good
that's not good that's really not
good
okay to it down oh boy okay so right now
average is 154 and then Max is
242 beautiful numbers for returnal lots
of things going on right
now nope nope nope that Tim
R we's doal with that closest to
you
yep okay we're fine all good we are
currently
at 149 FPS for average and 242 FPS Max
so is making a short work of these games
anyway this R ever2 build is a fiery
Fighter for performance which embodies
Asuka perfectly let's just quickly recap
the FPS performance for the three games
we played for armor core 6 we had an
average of 119. 3 FPS with a maximum of
237.55 SPS Starfield came back with an
average of 135 FPS and a maximum FPS of
234 lastly Ral played out with an
average of
and a maximum FPS of
241.55 SPS given the specs this thing is
the dream build for every PC and Evan
gon fan out there and gaming on it with
the strict scope RX and Gladius 3 AO
ever 2 peripherals makes quite a
difference given how the feel of the
keyc caps and switches are the
lightweight factor of the Gladius 3 lets
me slide off stop and input my clicks
when and wherever I need to exactly even
if you're not going to f out the price
of raising a newborn child into their
first year of existence
take a look and give R's puros an actual
shot and I think you'd be just as
surprised as I am besides that if you
have any questions about the PC let us
know in the comments below and if you
like what we do hit the like And
subscribe buttons it goes a long way
this is Zeno have a great week and if
you want to see more stuff check this
out